[MUSIC PLAYING]
[THE HUNTS, "HEAVEN KNOWS"]
(SINGING) 1, 2, 3, 4.
Ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh.
Ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh.
Ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh,
ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh.
Ooh, ooh, ooh.
Hey, hey, hey!
Ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh.
Ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh.
Ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh,
ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh.
Ooh, ooh, ooh.
Are you ready, dear?
Oh, we must be sure.
There's no turning back
once we're out the door.
Leave your message
here on the telephone,
'cause we've no idea
when we're coming home.
Any place we wander to,
any season we go through,
I'll be fine as long as
I'm with you, heaven knows.
Heaven knows.
Running 'round the world
with you, when you smile,
I smile too.
How I ever made it
without you, heaven knows.
Heaven knows.
I feel the weather changing,
better get out soon.
Don't let go of my hand
no matter what you do.
Well I'm here for you
through the thick and thin.
We're on a winding
road that never ends.
Any place we wander to,
any season we go through,
I'll be fine as long as
I'm with you, heaven knows.
Heaven knows.
Running 'round the world
with you, when you smile,
I smile too.
How I ever made it
without you, heaven knows.
Heaven knows.
Oh, hey!
My oh my, remember when we
were just becoming friends?
You took my hand
for a dance, and I
have loved you ever since.
The storm is on our heels,
and we'll be swept away.
We better run, run, run, honey.
What you say?
Gonna be all right
with you by my side.
I can't believe you're mine.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Colorado, where will we go?
Oh, Virginia, I wanna show ya.
Anywhere, I'll take you
there, heaven knows.
Heaven knows.
Colorado, where will we go?
Oh, Virginia, I wanna show ya.
I'll be fine as long as
I'm with you, heaven knows.
Heaven knows.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh.
Ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh.
Yeah, I'll be fine as long as
I'm with you, heaven knows.
Heaven knows.
[CHEERING]
JOSH HUNT: Thank you.
Thanks so much.
That song, we just
released a music video
for over the summer.
Really fun.
And we're playing songs off
of our new record called
"Darlin' Oh Darlin'".
So this next song is on there,
and it's called "Love of Mine."
[THE HUNTS, "LOVE OF MINE"]
(SINGING) Oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, um.
Ah, ah, ah, ah,
ah, ah, ah, ah, ah.
Ah, ah, um.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, um.
Ah, ah, ah, ah,
ah, ah, ah, ah, ah.
Ah, ah, um.
Mountains towering
again in your mind.
Aren't they the
hardest ones to climb?
Darling, look how far we've
come simply by taking it
one step at a time.
Oh, oh, oh, I want you to know
you're not in this on your own,
oh, because, darling, I
would never let you go.
Oh, oh, oh, and I'm willing to
lose anything if I have you.
Darling, no matter what it
takes, we'll make it through.
No matter what it
takes, we'll make it.
I don't have many fancy
things to my name.
Aren't they fleeting anyway?
But I'm more fortunate than I
have been told now that I've
found your heart of gold.
Oh, honey, well, I'd never
guarantee we'll be fine.
Aren't we given
one day at a time?
Love of mine, I know
everything can change.
Let it change.
But I'll still fall
for you everyday.
Oh, oh, oh, I want you to know
you're not in this on your own,
oh, because, darling, I
would never let you go.
Oh, oh, oh, and I'm willing to
lose anything if I have you.
Darling, no matter what it
takes, we'll make it through.
Oh, don't be afraid, my dear,
'cause I'm not going anywhere.
You know that I'll
be there for you.
No matter what it takes,
we'll make it through.
[CHEERING]
JENNI HUNT: Thank you so much.
It's so good to be here.
We were here in
September, and we got
our minds blown by the tour.
Madison gave us a tour, and
we heard about the talks.
And she got us connected, so
we're really stoked to be here
and to be a part of this today.
And we were just in Denver.
We had a show at the
BOB, Brew on Broadway,
and it was cool to reconnect.
And so we come this
way a few times a year,
and so hopefully,
we'll get to see
you guys again, and with
the full band and all
the amps and everything.
But this is cool in a
little acoustic set.
We've got one more
song off of our--
this is a single
off of our record.
And Josh wants to make
sure that you know--
JOSH HUNT: Yeah, I don't know
if we told you guys or not.
We're all brothers
and sisters up here,
and if you saw the picture,
we're missing one sister.
She just had a baby, like, last
month, so we kind of-- yeah.
JENNI HUNT: Yeah.
JOSH HUNT: We're
excited about that.
We're heading home
from here, so we're
excited to kind of
reconnect and see him again.
He's just a month old now.
So we decided not to
bring her on tour with us.
[LAUGHTER]
JENNI HUNT: All right, this is
a single off our new record.
It's called "Along the Way."
[THE HUNTS, "ALONG THE WAY"]
(SINGING) 2, 3, 4.
Follow me to my favorite tree.
Well, I'm offering
a steady hand.
I could be your
security, but there's
no guarantee on anything.
And I'll take care of you
along the way, my love.
One day at a time, we'll
leave our troubles behind.
And you'll take care of
me along the way, my love.
One day at a time, we'll
leave our troubles behind.
Here with you in our
treetop view, well,
it takes me to when I was young.
I fell before, but I can't
ignore that it's nothing
like I'm falling now.
No, it's nothing
And I'll take care of you
along the way, my love.
One day at a time, we'll
leave our troubles behind.
And you'll take care of
me along the way, my love.
One day at a time, we'll
leave our troubles behind.
Yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
Ooh, ooh, oh.
Uh-huh, ooh, ooh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Ooh, ooh, oh.
Uh-huh, ooh, ooh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh!
And I'll take care of you
along the way, my love.
One day at a time, we'll
leave our troubles behind.
And you'll take care of
me along the way, my love.
One day at a time, we'll
leave our troubles behind.
One day at a time.
One day at a time, we'll
leave our troubles behind.
[CHEERING]
JOSH HUNT: Thank you.
SPEAKER 1: So we did a quick
intro in the beginning,
but if we could go through and
get everyone's names and what
instruments you play.
JORDAN HUNT: OK, we can
start here and go down.
I'm Jordan.
Nice to meet you guys.
I'm the drummer
of the band, and I
play a couple other instruments,
like guitar, ukulele.
And those are my main
three that I stick to.
Yeah.
JAMISON HUNT:
Hello, I'm Jamison.
I play mandolin, banjo, guitar,
ukulele, also play drums.
Started on violin,
but about that--
that's about it.
JOSH HUNT: I'm Josh.
I play guitar, and I sing.
And I do play the bass,
and I started on violin.
And I can play a couple
others, but not well.
So we won't count those.
JENNI HUNT: I'm Jenni.
And I mostly sing for the group,
and I also play the violin.
We didn't bust it out
today because of the songs,
but that's my
passion, is violin.
And actually, Josh
and I write a lot
of the lyrics for the group, and
so that's another passion too.
JOHN HUNT: All right.
I'm John, and I play keys,
and accordion, and basically
anything that looks like
piano, a little bit.
And a little bit of guitar.
And-- yeah.
JUSTIN HUNT: I'm Justin,
and I play the bass.
And I play, like, 14
different instruments, so--
and yes, they're all
stringed instruments.
SPEAKER 1: OK, so
that was 17 plus 14.
We're missing Jessi.
What does Jessi play?
JOSH HUNT: Jessi plays
banjo, mandolin, violin,
viola, guitar.
Yeah, I think that's
about it, maybe.
I'm probably missing some.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
JOSH HUNT: It's always hard.
We always get that question,
like, how many instruments
do you guys play?
And it's like we've never really
come up with a specific number.
It's just like we all
kind of play instruments
that we don't know if we
can count or not, so yeah.
In the show, though,
I think we came up
with a number of
around 12 or 13.
I can't remember though.
SPEAKER 1: So obviously a very
musically talented family.
For reference, I
play the clarinet,
so that's all so much cooler.
JOSH HUNT: Yeah, none
of us can do that.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: So how did
the band get started?
Who was the first to
pick up an instrument?
What's kind of the origin story?
JENNI HUNT: Yeah, so our
story, like most of us
said, we started on
classical violin, actually.
Our mother was a music
major in college,
and so she started a
violin school in Virginia,
where we grew up.
And so we were just
always playing,
you know, Bach and Mozart
and Beethoven and Vivaldi.
And at a certain
point-- well actually,
all the while, our dad was just
this electric guitar shredder.
And he was, like, listen to Led
Zeppelin, and here's Boston.
And learn this solo.
And so we definitely
had these two worlds
of music influencing us,
two very different worlds.
And our mom would take
us to the library,
and she'd say, pick
out any CD you want.
And we'd all come back
with Motown CDs from--
I remember NSYNC was
a favorite one too.
And from just every genre we
could listen to, we would.
And then, probably
around teen years,
we started writing our own
music and branching off.
And we need-- if we want a
band, if we want to write music,
we need that full sound.
So people gravitated
to what they
were interested to-- the drums,
and the keys, and guitars,
and the bass.
And we definitely use the
whole team, kind of rely
on each other's strengths,
so as far as lyrics go.
And John really composes
a lot of the melodic side
of the songs.
And Justin's the gear
tech guy, the engineer
for recording and demos
and that sort of thing.
And Jord brings the songs
to life with the pulse,
and the beat, and the rhythm.
So yeah, it's a big team effort.
SPEAKER 1: So it's
very collaborative.
No one just goes off into a room
and then comes back and says,
hey, here's a song
we're going to play?
JENNI HUNT: Well,
sometimes that happens,
and we're open for
any creative flow.
Sometimes it's a big jam
session with everyone,
and sometimes it's those
personal times of writing
and personal experience.
And then you bring it
and show it to everyone,
and they take it to a new place.
JOSH HUNT: Yeah, it's never been
the same for us in songwriting.
I don't think we have
any two songs that
were written the same way.
But with one of the songs we
played today, the first one,
"Heaven Knows," I
remember we were
trying to write lyrics to it.
And we were just
like, OK, we really
need a chorus to this song.
Everybody break for an hour,
and you can write by yourself
if you want.
You can pair up with
somebody if you want.
And just come back, and
we're going to show and tell.
And so from that, I mean,
it was kind of tough,
because you're like,
I don't want to show.
I'm not that proud of this.
But we would pick and
choose from each person what
was really good and kind
of mash it all together.
So that one's one of
my favorite examples,
because I can listen
to the chorus in that
and hear three or four different
people's influence in it.
SPEAKER 1: Very cool.
What does the recording
process look like for you guys?
Is it just everyone get a room,
and we're going to bang it out,
or--
JENNI HUNT: You want
to talk, recording guy?
JOSH HUNT: Yeah, recording has
also looked different for us
through the years.
We've gone to
different studios--
one in Virginia, one in
Nashville, one in Connecticut,
the most recent.
And we definitely
are trying to--
the recording process
for us, we feel
like would be best if we
could just relax and sit
in our own home
or studio, and you
don't feel like you're
on the clock every minute
of every day.
JUSTIN HUNT: Yeah,
so the next album
is going to be released
in eight years, probably.
That's when it's
going to be ready.
JOSH HUNT: So we got
a bunch of equipment,
and we're going to try and
record our own stuff from here
on out.
JUSTIN HUNT: Heck yeah.
JOSH HUNT: More to add to that?
Justin interned at the studio
in Connecticut for a month
and learned a bunch of stuff.
And so we're kind
of, yeah, hoping
to put the Hunts'
future in his hands.
SPEAKER 1: Where do you guys
draw most of your inspiration
and your influence
for your music?
JOHN HUNT: Usually I like
just finding a quiet room.
A lot of times,
it's during a party,
for some reason, when
I write the best.
But it's like I can always
hear on my voice memos
that there's a party.
I was like, oh, that's
when they were over,
and I went back in a quiet
room and just kind of started
messing around.
So that's usually when
I feel most inspired.
JOSH HUNT: Yeah,
a lot of our music
has been inspired
by our childhood,
and also the idea of traveling.
And then more recently, the
latest album was inspired
by our commitment, I guess.
Our grandparents were
a really good example
to us of commitment, and
they're committed to each other.
And so if you see
the album there,
it's our grandparents on
the front of the album.
And so it's just kind of
whatever you're feeling
is what you really
want to write about.
It's a lot of times
really hard for us
to write when it's
like, we have this song,
and it really needs lyrics.
And it's super happy.
But you're not feeling
that at the moment,
so you kind of want
to sit back and maybe
work on something else.
We're always trying to figure
out how to write where we are
and something that
relates to all of us,
and not just one or two people.
JORDAN HUNT: I
typically write off
of emotions, where when I
experience something that
invokes an emotion that
I, then, am inspired
to write a song about, like
the most recent one today
that you got to hear.
SPEAKER 1: Do you want to tell
us about the most recent one?
JORDAN HUNT: Sure.
Yeah, we're trying to
release a new song,
and it kind of
features me coming out
from behind the drums and
playing guitar and leading it.
And just a few months
ago back in Virginia,
I went into a Chick-fil-A, and
there was a pretty girl there
working the cash register.
And so I left there, and
I just had those feelings,
and so I wrote this song.
Just kind of that nervous,
I want to get to know you,
but how do I even do
this, kind of thing.
And so I wrote a song about
that, and it's a fun jam.
And so we're trying to release
that this summer in June.
And so be on the
lookout for that.
SPEAKER 1: And
you will know when
you hear the song that
it was about the cashier
at Chick-fil-A.
JORDAN HUNT: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Have you
spoken to her since?
JORDAN HUNT: No, no.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: Chalk that one
up to unrequited love.
[LAUGHTER]
So, Josh, you mentioned travel
being a big inspiration,
and you guys are
on tour right now.
How has that been going?
JOSH HUNT: It's
been going great.
This tour we've
been really focusing
on lyrics, because that,
for us, really holds us up.
We have a lot of
instrumentalists
that just compose and
write beautiful melodies.
Jamison and Jonathan have
been putting together
a lot recently.
And they're like, we
have this whole album,
but right now it's instrumental,
and it needs lyrics.
So this tour was
focus on lyrics tour,
and we've been doing that.
And definitely
incredible inspiration
comes from incredible sights.
You know, we're driving
through the Rockies,
and we're getting
out to the coast.
And up in Washington,
snowy mountains
and just beautiful scenery
has really inspired us.
And I think that you may be
able to decipher or pick out
some of that in our
future work, hopefully.
I mean--
JENNI HUNT: So that's
been on the road
to pass the time,
kind of a challenge
that we've been tasked
with, to write lyrics.
But what's also been
cool for me this tour
is just a group of seven
siblings from Virginia,
all the way on the edge
of that east coast,
to come all the way
out to Washington,
and Oregon, and Utah.
And that there are
people who actually
show up and know our songs
has been mind-blowing to me.
And super cool, as
a band, to see that
actually through the digital
age that your music can really
spread across the country.
Even though having never been
there or met these people,
they feel like they know
us and know our music.
So that's been a really
cool experience this tour.
SPEAKER 1: Awesome.
So you guys were in
Denver a couple weeks ago,
and you're no
strangers to Colorado.
We get the shout-out
in the song.
JOSH HUNT: Ah, yes.
SPEAKER 1: You guys
have also played
Red Rocks, which is the ultimate
mecca for concert goers.
What was that experience like?
JENNI HUNT: So Red Rocks
we were touring with OAR.
We got to open for them
for their summer tour.
And we saw that Red
Rocks was on the tour,
and we were looking
at that, like,
but we're probably not going
to get to open for them
that night, right?
And when they told us, no, heck
yeah, you guys are opening.
You're our opener for this.
We were like, are you serious?
We get to do that?
So it just felt like a
once-in-a-lifetime experience.
And you can walk down
the halls backstage,
and there are these posters
of every band that's
played the stage.
And it just felt
like a huge honor.
Jord had a crazy
experience at Red Rocks--
JORDAN HUNT: Yeah.
JENNI HUNT: --with the--
no pretty girls this time,
but the elevation really
got to him.
JORDAN HUNT: Yeah, so had driven
in that night for soundcheck,
loaded the stage.
And everybody was running
up and down the stairs,
and I was like,
oh, I can do that.
So I ran up, and I
sprinted to the top.
And I came back down, and
when I was coming down,
I was like, oh, I didn't
even look at the view
when I was up there.
So like I just
continued, went up again.
And these guys
were watching, so I
was like, I gotta be fast
when they're watching.
So I just was going at it.
And when I got up to the top,
I was like, oh my goodness,
what is this feeling?
And I passed out.
[LAUGHTER]
I passed out at the top.
Didn't get a good
look at the view up
there, but it was
an hour before show.
And so they had a medical
room right next to the stage,
because apparently this
happens a lot to the artists.
[LAUGHTER]
So they strap me to
this chair, and it
was going down the stairs.
I'm throwing up,
and it was great.
It was a great story, right?
[LAUGHTER]
And so five minutes
before the show,
these guys were
trying to figure out
how to do the show
without the drums.
And so I was laying there
with an IV in my arm.
I was like, I have
to do the show.
My hands were cramping, but
five minutes before the show,
I stood up and saw how,
like, I felt standing up.
I felt like a zombie.
Walked out on stage, and
adrenaline kicked in,
and I was able to
like do the show.
But that was my Red
Rocks experience.
SPEAKER 1: Jordan, why do I feel
like you have the best stories?
[LAUGHTER]
Do you want to tell
the crowd surfing one?
JORDAN HUNT: Oh.
No.
JOSH HUNT: Yeah.
I'll tell it.
[LAUGHTER]
JENNI HUNT: Every drummer is
the one with the best stories,
I feel like.
JOSH HUNT: We've crowd
surfed twice in our lives.
Actually, Jamison crowd surfed.
We played a--
JAMISON HUNT: Mine
was successful.
JOSH HUNT: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
We played at college, and
there was this other big band
that dropped out.
And we filled in, so
it was this huge crowd
that I wasn't expecting us.
And they were great.
And just Jamison went
out, and because it
was such a huge crowd,
he just crowd surfed.
And it was a first for
the band, really cool.
The next year, we went
back to the college.
And so we're like, we've got
to keep the tradition alive.
And Jordan went out.
And it was in the
auditorium, so there
were these rows of chairs.
And so people are
kind of spaced out.
Yep.
JORDAN HUNT: And so
what they did was
they kept pushing me back until
there wasn't anybody anymore.
And then I was
just on the chairs.
Yeah.
So my ribs felt pretty
good after that.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: Thank
you for sharing.
When you guys aren't crowd
surfing or passing out
at Red Rocks or
anything, what do you
like to do on your
off days on tour?
JOSH HUNT: Yeah,
that always changes.
We definitely sightsee
wherever we are.
We went through a
disk golf phase,
where we would get out of
the RV and find a course
and go disk golfing.
But most recently it's been
rock climbing, bouldering.
A few of us are
really into that,
and just started a
little over a year ago
and are going twice a week now.
So whenever we can get out
and find a new rock gym,
it's the coolest thing.
JENNI HUNT: We love
hikes and waterfalls.
And so we were just in
Oregon, so we probably
saw seven waterfalls.
And then we went
to Cannon Beach.
Everybody said we
had to get out there.
And there's actually a
waterfall at Hug Point going out
onto the beach.
I have a little two-year-old,
and he was just loving it.
And I just have a feeling when
we get back to Virginia Beach,
he's going to ask
me, mom, where's
the waterfall on our beach?
And it was just
really beautiful,
and we love that kind of thing.
JORDAN HUNT: Also love looking
for ski slopes and stuff
when we're out in
Colorado or wherever
that have mountains
like this where
we can find some ski slopes.
But my dad is always
like, no, we're on tour,
and you're going to get hurt.
But--
SPEAKER 1: He has a good point.
[LAUGHTER]
JENNI HUNT: Knowing
your track record.
JOSH HUNT: Yeah.
JORDAN HUNT: Hey, yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Cool.
So, Jenni, you mentioned
that you have a son,
and obviously Jessi is out
because she has two sons now.
Do we see a musical
future for them?
JENNI HUNT: Yeah, I think so.
Right now, my son
is loving the drums.
He just likes to beat the
heck out of Jordan's drums,
and he likes the songs.
Actually, his new favorite
song is the new one coming out,
Jord's "Life is Good" song.
And--
SPEAKER 1: Chick-fil-A girl.
JORDAN HUNT: Yes.
JENNI HUNT: But right
now, I can definitely
see he's obsessed
with anything sport.
So I feel like he's
naturally drawn to that too,
but I definitely want
him to learn music.
SPEAKER 1: Cool.
So we're going to
open it up to Q&A.
If anyone wants to come
up and ask a question,
come steal the mic from me.
But before that, what is the
last thing that you Googled?
JORDAN HUNT: Probably for me,
it would probably be the Hunts.
[LAUGHTER]
JOSH HUNT: You Googled us?
JORDAN HUNT: I like to see
how our page looks sometimes.
I don't have social
media or anything,
and so I always check in on
the Hunts through Google.
So thank you guys.
[LAUGHTER]
JAMISON HUNT: I looked up
adjustable phone holders.
[LAUGHTER]
JOSH HUNT: My most recent was
a bouldering gym in Boise.
Yeah, we found a cool one there.
JENNI HUNT: Well, I use the
Google search on the hourly.
And it's usually like health
benefits of chia seeds
or something like that.
But then, similar to
Jordan's, I posted--
it was my fifth year anniversary
with my husband on March 30.
So I posted some of our lyrics
with the post on Instagram.
And so I was like, I
wonder, if somebody
were to type in these lyrics
into the search engine,
if they'd actually show up.
And that was super
cool that it brought up
our website and the lyrics.
And that was super
cool to see, kind
of that personal connection.
Yeah.
JOHN HUNT: I think I
looked up-- what was it--
how to make money on YouTube.
[LAUGHTER]
Because we just
released a video.
We've been releasing videos
at the start of this year
and have no idea
how money-making
really works on that.
So just kind of looked that up.
So yeah, you should check
out some of our new videos--
[LAUGHTER]
--so we can make some money.
JUSTIN HUNT: Let's see.
It was how to get a Hunts
song on a Google commercial.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: Speaking
of which, you guys
were featured on MTV
recently, correct?
JORDAN HUNT: Yeah.
JOSH HUNT: Mm-hmm.
JENNI HUNT: Yeah, I
think they've featured
two of our songs on MTV.
And we actually got a Milk-Bone
dog biscuits commercial
a couple years ago and, I think,
a couple online commercials.
And Starbucks has got
us on their playlist,
so that's always really
exciting as a band
to see your music being
synced with these companies
and commercials.
SPEAKER 1: So if anyone's
watching that has the hook up--
JOSH HUNT: We've
got songs for you.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: Cool.
Does anyone from the
audience have any questions?
AUDIENCE: I do.
SPEAKER 1: Oh, we
got one up here.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious
about the sibling dynamic.
Are there other siblings, or
are all of you in the band?
And then as you were
growing up, was it
just natural that
you felt like, yeah,
this is what I want to do?
Are there some of you who
are kind of like, yeah,
this is the second
thing that I do,
but I have other things
that are more primary.
And did you feel like you
have to be in the band?
And then also, in terms
of just getting along,
I have a lot of children, and
they don't always get along.
[LAUGHTER]
What are some, I guess, just
interesting stories, or just
the relationship dynamic
that you have there
as you're working
together as a band,
but then also you've had this
whole experience growing up
together?
JORDAN HUNT: Yeah.
Well, as far as the siblings
wanting to do music,
we grew up-- our parents
were music lovers.
And so we grew up under that
household of loving music,
and so it was our passion as
kids to learn an instrument.
And our parents would play
around at little events,
like weddings and
things like that.
And so when-- the
girls are the oldest.
When they were like six, they
were twins playing violin.
They added them into
their act, and everybody
loved seeing the little
kids play violin.
And so when Josh was old
enough, he got into the band,
and then everybody
thought, well,
when am I getting into the band?
So it's was our passion.
We weren't forced
to do anything.
We loved doing it.
And even now, nobody is forced
to be a part of the band.
We all love doing this.
This is what we love to do.
And the door is open for--
we've had this conversation
multiple times.
If anybody has something else,
like the girls, if they're
like, I just want to
be a stay-at-home mom
and raise my children,
we're not like,
no, you're chained to the band.
So everybody's in because
they want to be in,
and they love to be here.
Yeah.
JENNI HUNT: I remember
at a certain point
when the older siblings felt
like, we're the cool ones,
and the younger ones
are the baby ones.
We're going to go away
and do this music retreat.
The younger two
siblings said, what?
You're not leaving
us out of this.
And we kind of had a talk
with them like, well,
we're trying to be serious here.
We're trying to
be a serious band.
We're trying to be cool.
And if you're going
to do this, you
need to show that
you're ready for that.
And they really did step it up.
And I can't imagine the
band without them now
and their influence and all the
work that they've put into it.
So I think the sibling rivalry
thing, that's always something
families will have to work out.
And we have to recommit
to each other every day
about forgiving
each other and grace
and being committed to each
other first and then the band.
But, yeah, everyone
has other passions
too that we like to fill in our
time when we're not traveling.
But it's been really cool
to work hard at this.
And I'm really proud
of everyone for pushing
through the ups and the
downs and making it happen.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
guys for being here.
This has been so awesome.
Kind of going off
the sibling dynamics,
you mentioned you
travel in an RV.
Do you guys all fit in one,
or is it like a caravan?
JENNI HUNT: Yeah, good question.
So we barely fit in one.
We're maxed out right now.
It technically sleeps 10,
but that's uncomfortably 10,
and if you're really short.
Yeah.
So I'm fine, but some of
the taller guys are like,
this isn't working.
JOSH HUNT: We're sleeping
at an angle on a two-seater.
JENNI HUNT: And we have a
trailer with all the gear
because we typically travel
with our own sound, and merch,
and all of that.
So right now that
works, but we actually
did just have a talk about
maybe investing in another RV,
because the entertainment
coaches are a little bit out
of the budget--
or way out of the budget.
But trying to make
it work with kids
coming into the family, and
girlfriends, and husbands,
and all of that.
So, yeah, trying
to make it work.
JOSH HUNT: And as far
as the dynamic goes,
I think we were kind
of groomed for it.
We grew up in a
three-bedroom house--
all five guys in one room, two
bunk beds and a roll-out bed,
and then my sisters
in another room.
And we all shared one bathroom.
JENNI HUNT: Which is the
same story on the RV.
There's a little
bathroom in there.
JOSH HUNT: Yeah, so we would get
home from tour to that house,
and that would feel
really big to us.
We've upgraded
since we were kids.
But also, just depending on
how long we're on the road,
we just have to be really--
what's a good--
JENNI HUNT: What, patient?
JOSH HUNT: --word for that?
Yeah, patient with each
other, because, I mean,
you're with somebody
for a really long time,
and you do get
kind of irritable.
My mom always would
bring up this example.
She's like, even if
you put rats together
for a really long time,
they start fighting.
And we're like, thanks, Mom.
[LAUGHTER]
But we always have to find
that redemption and resolve.
AUDIENCE: How do you
decide which instruments
you're playing for which songs?
And when you are trying
to figure out, OK, well,
how do we play without the
drums, or something like that,
do you have people that would
rotate in different roles?
How would that work?
JOHN HUNT: Yeah.
So usually the person who
started the song a lot of times
will be playing it on
guitar, or piano, or whatever
they started on.
And they're like, I kind
of want to play this part.
This is my part that I made up.
It's kind of first-come,
first-served sometimes.
So like whoever makes up a
part on whatever instrument
gets that instrument
for that song,
unless it's like completely--
I mean, what would
you call that?
We have to be able to change
between songs relatively quick.
So if it's ridiculous,
then we'll--
JOSH HUNT: We all have
our individual instruments
that we kind of gravitated to.
And I pretty much just
stay on the guitar,
and I'll switch over to
bass for a song or two.
But now, some of
these other guys
are writing songs
and coming forward
and playing and singing.
And I look to the
bass, and Justin's
over there on the
bass, like, uh-uh,
I already have a
really cool part.
[LAUGHTER]
And now I'm like, OK, so do I
just stand over on the corner
and sing harmony?
And so I've been picking
up other instruments too.
And that's kind
of, I think, how it
worked when we were younger
for the younger guys.
It was like, OK,
what's left over,
and what would sound good?
JUSTIN HUNT: Yeah, I think
that's how we used to do it.
I think more
recently, we're trying
to look at the vision
of the song and be like,
does electric guitar
belong on this song?
Yeah, maybe it does.
Or we'll be like, no
banjo on the song.
So we all have a vision of--
I don't know-- what the
song needs, I would say.
JORDAN HUNT: Yeah.
And I feel like my job is
the easiest out of them,
because I stick to the
drums most of the time.
Pretty much the whole
show I'm on the drums,
and then I have one song
that I'm just now coming
out and playing guitar.
And so then, that's when JJ
comes back and plays drums.
And that's when
other people have
to switch what they
usually do, because I'm
taking their instrument.
But for me, it's pretty easy.
But as far as how you
choose what part to play,
you just pick up your
instrument, whatever you're on,
and you go off of what
you feel like it needs.
And then everybody gives input
to everybody's instrument,
like, what do you think
of playing this fill here?
JOSH HUNT: Or not playing that.
JORDAN HUNT: Or not
playing that fill there.
Yeah.
Just everybody gives input
to what everybody plays.
And so we're all
like seven filters
that every part has to go
through before it makes it
on the album.
AUDIENCE: So
following on that too,
do you do everyone
on every song,
or are there some songs
where somebody's like,
I'm going to sit this one out?
JENNI HUNT: Since
all seven siblings
are going to be on
stage for every song,
we try to find a part.
And sometimes it is
just harmonizing vocally
or getting on the tambourine.
Because I play
violin, and if a song
isn't conducive to the
strings, then I'll just sing.
And it's a good challenge,
though, to force yourself
to learn something
new, or even to feel
comfortable without hiding
behind an instrument,
to just be able to
stand up there and sing
and be confident in that.
It's always a
challenge, and I feel
like we're always
growing and pushing
each other to the next level.
And like Justin said,
that vision for the song,
too, that's what's worth
it, and to challenge
ourselves to get there.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I was
curious about just how you
settled on a sound.
You know, you talk about
your background of classical
and more classic rock,
and then how you all
come together to
say, yeah, we like
this feel, this sound together.
I've only heard the three
songs you played today,
so I don't if you have a broader
range that you do as well.
JENNI HUNT: So the sound
of the band, the genre.
It's always hard to put a
finger on naming the genre,
but I think when, before we
wrote our original music,
we were a cover band,
we'd just play anything.
And we really wanted to zero in
on who are the Hunts, and what
is our sound.
And it took a couple of
years to really get there.
But I think through
that journey we
realized we like to tell
stories with our lyrics.
It's very personal,
and we're drawn
to the acoustic instruments--
mando, banjo, guitar, strings.
And so we felt like that kind
of a folk sound really blended
with the storytelling.
And now, in our big sets,
Jamison's got the mando
going through pedals
and amps, and we've
got some amplification
and some effects,
which really causes this
fusion of alternative folk
and ambience.
And we're really liking that.
But yeah, it was
definitely a couple years
of journey
discovering our sound.
JUSTIN HUNT: Yeah, I
think we're all really--
we like different music.
Jordan likes-- he likes
different music than I like.
And--
[LAUGHTER]
Different.
And so we're all very--
I like more electronic
stuff, and then
some people like acoustic stuff.
So we all kind of know
what the Hunts sounds like,
and we kind of go for
that sort of vision.
JOSH HUNT: I think a big part
of our sound that we're just
now realizing is
siblings harmonizing.
I've heard there's
something there,
like versus strangers
harmonizing.
So I think that plays a
big role in our sound.
It's just vocals and harmony.
AUDIENCE: With all of your
different music tastes,
I'm curious to see what your
favorite band or artist has
been recently.
JOSH HUNT: OK, cool.
One of my favorites--
well, I have so many
it's hard to pick one.
I typically like a lot
of singer-songwriters.
Or just not so
much, maybe, vocally
great, but lyrically rich.
So like Bob Dylan, or Leonard
Cohen, or Damien Rice,
Keaton Henson are some
of my real favorites.
And then bands,
there's a band called
Dry the River that has been
my favorite for a while now.
JORDAN HUNT: Yeah, for me,
I feel like the latest band
that I got into a lot
was Cage the Elephant.
But my favorite
band is Sigur Rs,
because, just how like I was
saying I write out of emotion,
I feel like their band
does the same thing.
They just write out
of deep emotions,
and I connect to that.
Like, I don't know what he's
saying because he's singing
in a different language.
But I really--
I connect to the
emotions that the songs
are giving and everything,
so that's my favorite band.
JUSTIN HUNT: Yeah,
I like music that's
really had some serious
production go into it, so
like MGMT or The Flaming Lips.
That music isn't natural.
It's just made from all
this crazy recording stuff.
JORDAN HUNT: Yeah.
JOHN HUNT: Yeah, I'm
kind of like Josh
in I don't really
have favorites.
I like parts of a lot of bands.
A lot of times, I'm like, oh,
I don't like that side of them,
but I like this song.
So I guess some
older Arcade Fire.
I really like their older stuff.
And-- oh, what was it--
I like a lot of alt-J, in
that their beats and stuff are
really cool.
So yeah.
JAMISON HUNT: Yeah, I've been
currently listening to Dr. Dog.
That's a cool band there.
JENNI HUNT: I think if you
were to ask me and my sister,
we're oldies fans.
And Carole King and Mamas
and the Papas, I think,
did have a big influence
on us as younger people,
the layered vocals and stuff.
And so I'll never
get away from them.
But listening a lot right
now to two Swedish sisters,
First Aid Kit.
Love their sound
and their harmonies.
SPEAKER 1: Well, thank
you guys so much again
for coming and joining us,
for a wonderful performance
and great Q&A. And thank you,
everyone, for being here.
JOSH HUNT: Yeah, thanks so much.
JENNI HUNT: Thank you.
JORDAN HUNT: Yes, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]